The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
WILL MA: OK, guys, I
guess I'll get started.
So I guess one
quick announcement
is, so I guess everyone has
taken a look at the prizes.
If you can take a
look at the prizes
and, especially, if
you're near the top
and expect yourself to
be getting some prizes.
So we haven't announced
the final ordering yet,
because it'll also
depend on the homework
and then we'll decide how much.
It'll mostly just
be number of points,
but we might give
a bit of weighting
to people who have like a high
points per game or something.
But if you think you have
a decent chance of getting
prizes, it'd be good
if you looked them
over for when you research who
this Mike McDonald guy is, how
much is his coaching worth--
you can do that beforehand so
that people don't take forever
deciding which prize
you want on Friday.
OK, so I'm going to
get started then.
So this is going to be the
last class I'm going to teach.
So the final class,
on Friday, is
going to be guess-lectured
by Bill Chen.
So I want to go through an
in-depth combinatorial hand
analysis of a cash-game hand--
go very in depth on a hand
where you have deep stacks,
and there's a lot of action,
and there's a lot of deduction
that can take place.
And then I'll finish with
some general poker stuff
and answer any questions you
guys might have about the poker
economy, how certain things
work, the history of poker--
I'm happy to answer
whatever questions.
OK, so first, I'll do something
more technical and more
practical to the game.
So an in-depth combinatorial
hand analysis in cash games.
So I'm going to look
at the following hand.
And the board is visible?
It's good?
OK.
So this is a cash game.
This is no longer
a tournament now.
And everybody has
100 big blinds.
So the blinds are $1 and $2,
and everyone starts with $200.
So it's 100 big blinds.
The cutoff opens near six,
and we have eight-seven
suited on the button.
And when it's this
deep stacked--
so in a tournament,
this might not
be a good situation to
call, because it just puts
a lot of risk on you to bust.
And also, you're not
really that deep stacked.
But here, with
100 big blinds, we
can really realize a
lot of our implied odds
given that we're
both in position,
and we have a hand
that plays very well--
a suited connector-- that can
make straights and flushes.
So we decide to call, and
the big blind also calls.
OK, so the flop is 10,
eight, six with a club,
and the cutoff
continuation bet's 14.
So one thing I'll
talk about first
is, continuation bet sizing.
So I said a bit
about this, but I
wanted to talk a bit
more about bet sizing.
And this is really just
a review of what I've
been talking about all class.
It's the same principles when
deciding your flop and turn bet
sizing.
So you don't want to bet so
small that your opponent has
the odds to call with
anything, but you
don't want to bet so big that
you are risking a lot of chips
when you're bluffing.
And also, if your raise size
commits your entire stack
anyway, like if you're roughly,
let's say, betting 40% or more
of your remaining chips, then
you might as well go all-in
if it's the flop or the
turn because you probably
aren't going to fold.
Given that your
hand is good enough
to put in 40% of your
chips, you probably
have enough equity
that you're OK
putting in 100% of your chips.
Remember that raising your
bet gives them the option
to reraise, so that's
always an incentive
against raising a flop bet.
The sizing should be
bigger on dry boards
and smaller on dry boards.
We talked about this.
And you want to bet?
Bet a bit bigger when
they're out of position.
So he's kind of out of
position here against us,
and he bets 14 into 19, which
is a reasonably big bet,
but I think it's fine.
So with our hand here,
eight-seven of clubs,
I think we definitely
don't want to be folding.
So let's talk about
the differences
between raising and calling.
So we decide to call, and
so what's the analysis?
So we're definitely not folding.
Raising, I think,
is a bit suicidal
when we have a medium-strength
hand that can play well
in position on a lot of turns.
And we have a
backdoor flush draw;
and our straight
draw's very legitimate
when there is no
flush draw out there.
So we decide to just call.
We have to be a bit worried
about a big blind check-raise,
but I think it's OK.
It's not that big of a deal,
especially when there's
no flush draw.
So the big blind folds.
And on the turn is the queen
of clubs, and he bets 30.
OK, so this is sort of a tougher
decision now than the flop,
I'd say.
So let's analyze this.
So he bets 30 into 47,
we've got 180 behind,
which is about
four times the pot,
and we've got a pretty
bad hand right now,
but we still have
a pair, and we have
lots of chances to hit a
straight, or hit a flush,
or hit three of a
kind or hit two pairs.
So tons of outs-- tons of
river cards that help us.
And so what are the
benefits of each?
OK, so I think it's
fairly clear we're
not going to fold here
with this much equity.
So what are the
benefits of calling?
Well, we get to see the
river for sure, right?
If the river's a
club, then we don't
want to fold in
situations and not
see the river when it could
be a club, which is the best
card for us, essentially.
Yeah, so we really
want to see the river
because if we raise, then maybe
they could reraise all-in,
and then we would have to fold.
So that's one clear benefit.
And another sort of
benefit is, we already
have a pair to start with.
So we don't really need
to bluff to win a hand.
So this is something I've
been talking about a lot, too.
If you don't need to raise
to win the hand because you
already have a
pair, then there's
a lot more incentive to call.
So what are some
benefits of raising?
Well, if you get him to fold
something like pocket jacks--
if we think he might
have like pocket jacks--
it can definitely get him
to fold some better hands.
And we can bet the river and
win a bigger pot when we hit.
And we can also maybe make some
bigger bluffs when we miss.
So we'll go through a more
detailed analysis in a bit,
but I like calling
in this situation.
I think with a draw
that has no showdown
value, like say I had nine-five
of clubs instead of eight-seven
of clubs, which
has a pair, I think
I would raise for two reasons.
One is, I would need to
bluff the river anyway
if I miss the river.
So if I raise now, I
just give myself a chance
to win the pot right now.
And another benefit of
raising is that I can--
I'm not that unhappy
if he goes all-in
because my jaw is less strong
than eight-seven of clubs is.
OK, and then maybe with a
hand like ace-jack of clubs,
I would raise just because
we can maybe get it
in against weaker flush draws.
OK, so yeah, this is
a general principle
that I haven't really talked
about for playing on flops
and turns.
And this sort of
goes along with most
of the stuff we've talked
about in this class
but, in general, when you
have like the stone-cold nuts
and when you have
weaker draws, you
want to be the one-- you want to
be betting and raising in a way
such that your opponent
gets the last bet in.
So one person is always going
to go all-in first, right?
If you're raising each other
or betting and raising,
one person is going
to go on first,
and the other person,
basically, has
to decide whether to call or
fold and play for your stack.
So if you have the
stone-cold nuts,
then you want to be the person
having your opponent go all-in
first.
Because obviously, you
have a very easy decision.
You just call and
you're going to win.
On the other hand, if you
have like a weaker draw,
which is, essentially,
your bluff--
because we don't
want to be bluffing
with absolutely nothing.
We want to be
bluffing, basically,
with our weaker draws.
That's also an easy decision
because if, let's say,
we have a gutshot straight draw.
So we have four outs only.
We're not that sad if
our opponent goes all-in
on the flop or
all-in on the turn.
We just fold.
We have an easy
decision; whereas if we
have a more vulnerable
good hand-- like you
have top pair with a
medium kicker, then
it's a tough decision.
If our opponent goes all-in,
we have a tough decision.
We're not sure what to do.
And same if we have a
stronger draw-- like
say we have a flush draw,
and we have nine outs,
and then our opponent
goes all-in on the flop,
and we have like 1.61
odds to call or something.
It's a difficult decision.
And so in these
hands, you definitely
want to-- you
generally want to bet
and raise in a way that allows
you to get the last bet in.
Because with a stronger
draw, your opponent
gets to make a decision.
But even if they have the
nuts, you still have nine outs.
And with a more
vulnerable good hand--
I mean, if your
opponent has the nuts,
I guess you're kind
of dead, but you're
sort of protecting the
times you go all-in
with your stronger draws.
So following that principle,
I decide to just call here
because if I raise, then I have
to make a decision when he goes
all-in--
whether to call with my
medium-strength hand and pretty
good draw.
OK, so we call, and the
river's an ace of spades.
So we completely miss, and
our opponent checks to us.
So we decide to bluff
the river for 70.
And this is sort of the main
decision I want to analyze,
and it's going to be quite
a complicated decision.
So let's do some quick analysis.
So yes, we do have
some chances of winning
with our pair of eights.
So maybe you can make a
case that there's no need
to bluff because
we do have a pair,
but there's a lot
of reasons to bluff.
So one is, there's a lot of
higher cards on the board now.
The pair of eights-- they
looked pretty good on the flop,
but now it's a lot worse after
a queen turn and an ace river.
So we can get him
to fold a queen.
He can have a queen, and
he could very willingly
be able to fold it.
Also, the pot is big.
They bet the flop
and the turn, and we
called the flop and the turn.
So both ranges are just very
strong because so much money
has already gone in.
So a pair of eights
is not so good.
If you knew that he had
two random cards, sure,
a pair of eights will win a
decent percent of the time.
But when you know you're
up against a hand that
was willing to bet the
flop and bet the turn,
it's less likely the
pair of eights is good.
And then, the ace is
always a scary card.
And another advantage
of bluffing is--
this is why position
is so great--
especially when it's deep
stacked in a cash game.
We're in position, and we know
that he checked the river.
So maybe he's trapping
with like king-jack,
but it's more likely than not
that it's a sign of weakness
that he checked the river.
So we could try to
bluff him off his hand.
OK, so what about
river bet sizing?
So okay, so one thing
is whether the bluff.
Two, is if you bluff,
how much do you bet?
So I decided to bet 70 into 107.
And so what are the things
to consider when you're
deciding your river bet sizing?
So one is, there's no more
cards to come on the river.
So in some sense,
there's less of a worry
to betting really, really
small, because there
is no such thing as letting
your opponent see a draw.
But it still has a disadvantage.
Like if your opponent checks
to you and you bet small,
it still does give them
the option to check-raise.
So that is one thing you
worry about if you're
trying to bet really small.
And another thing is,
you should bet big
if your hand is polarized.
By polarized I mean, you
either have the stone-cold nuts
or you have a bluff.
Basically, if you bet small
and your range is polarized,
your opponent can just call
with a very wide range of hands
because their odds are too good.
By betting big, you give your
opponent worst odds to call,
and since you have a stone-cold
bluff some percent of the time,
you don't want your opponent
to have the odds to call
with like third pair.
OK so, it doesn't
matter what they
did, because our
decision is betting 70.
OK, so now what I
sort of want to do
is, a lot happened
this hand, right?
We know they raised the
preflop, bet flop, bet turn,
checked river.
So in some sense, we have
a ton of information.
So in the tournaments that you
play, maybe a hand like this
doesn't show up that
often because often it's
just an all-in preflop, and you
can't really deduce that much
about your opponent's hand.
It's just like, he has the
top 30% of hands or something.
But here, we can actually
do a lot of deduction.
So let's replay the hand from
our opponent's perspective
and sort of exploitatively
put them on a range.
So let's go put ourselves
in our opponent's shoes
and consider all the
actions they did.
So I'm going to use
exploitative analysis here.
So there are some
flaws with this.
We are sort of
arrogantly assuming
we're one step ahead
of our opponent--
we can build a mathematical
model for our opponent.
But still, this is a
useful exercise even
though, yes, there are flaws.
Maybe he's one step ahead of us.
Maybe there's flaws in
our probabilistic model.
But let's just assume for
the sake of the exercise
that we can do this pretty well.
OK, so first of all, preflop,
what's our opponent's range?
Let's just say, roughly,
he's opening from the cutoff.
Let's say he's opening
about 30% of hands.
I think that's about reasonable
for like an average player,
and I think it's consistent
with the guidelines
I gave in the first lecture.
So this includes any pair, any
suited ace, any two Broadway
cards, which are
cards 10 and higher.
It includes suited hands as
bad as five-three suited.
This is maybe one difference
between cash games
and tournaments, where
five-three suited
is a pretty bad hand in
tournaments when it's so short;
but when it's 100
big blinds deep,
a hand like five-three
suited is a lot better
than a hand like 10-8 offsuit.
So yeah, so it includes
five-three suited,
but not like nine-eight
off or like king-seven off,
which are just terrible hands
when it's 100 big blinds deep.
So OK, so what's our
opponent's range here?
So they decided to
continuation the bet.
They continuation bet into
the flop against two players
after the big blind check.
So what can we put him on?
OK, so this is a
complicated analysis,
and you can't really do
this during the game itself,
but it's very useful to
do it after the hand.
So let's review
the factors of why
a player would continuation
bet and then consider
why he continuation bets.
OK, so this is also
sort of a review
class since the last class.
So what are the incentives
for continuation betting?
Well, your hand is good
enough that it beats
most of their calling hands.
So you're betting for value or
your showdown value is poor,
but you have some equity.
You have some backdoor equity.
You have some
overcards or draws,
and you're,
essentially, bluffing.
Another incentive is, you're
out of position like he is,
and it's not like he
can see a free turn
card by checking because I
can still bet if he checks.
So you want to bet-- few
opponents, you want to bet.
Incentives against
continuation betting--
one is, your hand is
so dominant that you
need to give him a turn card
to hope that he improves.
So this is like the trap--
the slow play.
You have decent showdown
value, but not amazing showdown
value-- so like, middle pair.
You don't want a
continuation bet
if you have like zero equity
on a reasonably dry board
like this one.
And there's too many
people for you to fold out
or-- like you're in position,
and you can see a free turn
by checking.
So there's a lot of
things but, still,
let's look at the
situation again keeping
some of those factors in mind.
He continuation bet into 10,
eight, six rainbow, which
means three different suits.
OK, so actually, before
I show this slide,
I'm going to use the
annotate feature,
and we'll try to write
on here what hands we
think he can have.
So this is going
to take a while,
but I plan on spending
the next 20, 25
minutes discussing this hand.
OK, so does someone want
to say a hand that you
think is in this range at
this point in the hand?
Pretend we don't know what
he's going to do on the turn.
Yeah, just at this
point in the hand,
can someone tell me a hand
you think is in his range?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Ace-jack.
WILL MA: OK, yeah, ace/jack.
OK, I think that's reasonable.
It's actually, I
think, a bit weak.
But let's say like ace/jack
suited with a backdoor flush
draw.
OK, I'll write down
ace-jack for now.
OK, so someone go and
tell me another hand.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] pair.
Maybe 9-10, 10-jack suited?
Ace-10?
WILL MA: OK, ace-10--
sure, jack-10-- 10-9--
OK.
Someone want to tell me
another type of hand maybe?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
pocket jacks?
WILL MA: OK, good.
Pocket jacks, yeah.
So that's a clear value hand.
Someone want to tell me
another type of hand?
AUDIENCE: What about queen-jack?
WILL MA: Queen-jack.
OK, that's a good idea.
Yeah, that's a good one.
So Queen-jack I think is
one of the best draws--
not the best draw-- what is
the best draw, would you say?
AUDIENCE: Queen-jack of clubs?
WILL MA: Queen-jack of clubs,
yeah, but queen of clubs only--
it's not the best
straight draw, right?
Yeah, what's--
AUDIENCE: Jack-nine.
WILL MA: Yeah, jack-nine.
Jack-nine or queen-nine.
I wrote some hands here.
OK, jack-nine, or queen-nine,
or like five-seven.
OK.
AUDIENCE: One pair of sixes.
Is it possible?
WILL MA: Pocket sixes?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
WILL MA: Yeah, yeah,
OK, that's good.
So I'll write that down.
So pocket sixes, good.
OK, here's a question,
what do you guys want
to put him on if he has a
really, really good hand?
So this is open ended.
I didn't come with
a [INAUDIBLE]..
You guys want to assume that
he checks with pocket 10s
and like nine-seven--
basically the absolute best
hands on this board to trap us?
Or do you want to
assume that he bets?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: I think if
he has nine-seven,
he'd probably bet because
someone might get a better
straight if he doesn't bet.
WILL MA: OK, yeah that's
a reasonable assumption.
I think it can go either way
with nine-seven and like pocket
10s--
depending on our opponent.
Pocket sixes, I
think, is a clear bet,
whereas pocket 10s is not.
Because pocket 10s--
you're taking away so many
of the top hands
from your opponents,
whereas pocket sixes just gets
so much value when you bet.
OK, so roughly speaking,
I sort of categorized
all the hands he could
have into five categories.
So the first-- the
top is hands that
are so good that he checks
to trap or check-raise.
The second category
is like the hands
that are good but not
that good-- he value bets.
Then it's like
medium-strength hands
that he checks to check-call.
So this doesn't agree with
exactly what we wrote,
but that's OK.
But this is just roughly--
and then the next category
is hands that he bluffs.
And then the last category is
hands that he just check-folds
because they have no equity--
like pocket threes, where he
would just give up the hand.
So we basically crossed
off these three categories
because with these
three categories,
he would check, whereas the
top one, he's checking to trap;
the second one, he's
checking for a showdown;
and the last one, he's
checking to give up.
And then the two types
of hands he's betting
are, essentially, value bets
and like draws or bluffs.
OK, so now let's consider
the situation on the turn.
OK, so once again, let's
consider his incentives first
for betting again on the turn.
Sorry if this is a
bit hard to read.
Maybe I should do it on
notepad so that the annotate
isn't annoying.
Sorry, just give me a sec.
OK, so what are the incentives
for betting again on the turn?
So one is, you bet a good
hand for value on the flop,
and your hand is still
good on the turn.
So you're getting
for more value.
Two is, you bluffed a
speculative hand on the flop
and now you either
hit the turn--
like the queen helped you--
so like if you had jack-nine
or you improved your draw--
or like an overcard to the
board came, which was the case,
and maybe you thought bluffing
the turn could be good.
So OK, so he bet the turn.
OK, so let's maybe
put the hands we think
he could have into PokerStove.
So yeah, I think that's
the easiest way to do it.
OK, so let's do this.
OK, so roughly speaking--
can everyone see this?
This is easy enough
to see, right?
OK, so let's do this.
So bear with me.
This is a meticulous exercise.
OK, so let's say preflop, 30%--
OK, this is about reasonable.
Actually, let me give
him a few more pairs.
I'll take away ace-six off.
Let's say he goes
suited connectors down
to five-four suited,
suited one gappers down
to five-three suited--
suited two gappers.
So suited two gappers
means suited cards
that are three
apart, essentially.
Yeah, you have like eight-five
suited, something like this.
Something like this
is fine, probably,
but let's say he
plays 10-6 suited.
OK, something like this--
maybe take away some of
the worst offsuit hands.
OK, so something like this.
OK, good.
So on the flop, what happened?
On the flop-- we said, OK,
so let's eliminate hands.
What can we eliminate?
So this is his entire range
of possibilities, preflop.
OK, so on the flop,
we're going to eliminate
pocket twos, threes, fours, and
fives because he just gives up.
Pocket sevens and
nines we're going
to eliminate because we're
going to assume he checks.
Five-three is bad enough
we can assume he gives up.
Let me just display the
flop so that we can see.
OK, so what else?
OK, so let's go
through everything.
I'll deal with this a bit fast.
OK, let's say all
the middle pairs--
he's going to check.
So I'm going to remove most
of the hands with an eight
in them--
yeah, so ace-eight, king-eight,
queen-eight, jack, OK,
so 10-8 he's going to bet.
AUDIENCE: You do that just
because you have an eight?
AUDIENCE: Pretty much.
WILL MA: Yeah, so we will
take that into account.
But he could still
have an eight, right?
But yeah, you're right.
It is less likely, and we
will take it into account
at the very end.
So ace-five, let's assume--
let's assume a lot of
these offsuit aces,
he gives up because even with
overcards but with no backdoor
flush draw on a dry board,
I think is kind of scary.
OK, so let's say something
like this on the flop--
eight-five, let's
eliminate that.
Eight-seven, I
think he'll check.
So nine-seven, we're
going to assume he bets.
Let's assume he
checks pocket 10s.
Let's assumes he
also checks some
of the weaker
10s-- like jack-10,
let's suppose he checks.
Maybe 10-9, he checks as well.
10-7, he checks.
OK, nine-eight he checks.
OK, am I missing anything?
Did someone see something
you disagree with?
King-queen off, king-jack off--
I think those are
too weak, too--
that end of this board--
queen-nine, king-nine
suited, ace-nine down here.
OK, I think this is roughly--
it'll get easier on
the turn, basically.
OK, So let's say this is what
he's going to have on the flop.
Actually, some of
these weaker aces
probably should be eliminated.
OK, let's eliminate everything
down to ace-five and below.
Ace-seven and
ace-nine we'll keep in
because he has a straight draw.
OK, so on the turn,
he bets again.
So did someone want to
suggest a hand that maybe we
should eliminate
because he bet the turn?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Only
weak 10s, I guess?
WILL MA: OK, good.
Yeah, I think that's
a very good answer.
So let's get rid of ace-10
and king-10 because those
are no longer good hands-- or
they're no longer, I think,
hands that you want to really
continue betting for value,
right?
Queen-10 is good because
you hit two pair.
OK, is there another hand
that's of a similar category?
So I guess pocket jacks is
of a similar category, right?
It's not as good as it once was.
OK, so what are some
other hands maybe you
don't want to bluff with--
you don't want to
bet with anymore?
Are there any hands
you think maybe
he would just give up because--
AUDIENCE: The six-five.
WILL MA: Yeah, I think
that's reasonable.
Most of these, we
can assume he's
going to give up on the queen,
like five-four, especially.
So on the flop, he didn't
even have a great hand.
It was just drawing to a seven.
But now, it's sort of worse.
So yeah, let's get
rid of five-four.
Do you think they
would continue betting
like nine-six or seven-six?
Yeah, even seven-five
is a pretty bad--
is a lot worse after the
queen because seven-five
was like drawing to a nine.
But now, when the
queen comes, the nine
is not a good card because
you still lose to a jack.
So maybe we can get
rid of that one.
Do you think they
definitely continue
betting with ace-king,
ace-queen, ace-jack in all
those?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Maybe if
they had ace-queen,
they would keep it [INAUDIBLE]
pretend to [INAUDIBLE]..
WILL MA: Yeah, so
ace-queen, I think, is good.
All right, so I think
this is [INAUDIBLE] good.
Ace-nine-- some
of these hands, I
think they would probably
stop bluffing with.
Like I think jack-seven
suited is pretty--
maybe some of the sixes
also, I think, it's hard to--
even like ace-seven
suited, I think
it's hard to continue bluffing.
Because as we see,
there's already
enough hands with draws, right?
There are already a lot of
bluffs here like king-jack,
ace-king--
I guess like
queen-nine, nine-six,
some of these-- so yeah,
maybe he'll bluff with these,
but OK, let's get rid of these.
OK, so we've sort of cut
down his range a bit.
So now it's a river
situation, and he checks.
So what does this mean?
Well, it seems improbable
that their opponent
would be trying to
trap us with this check
because he's already been
showing plenty of aggression.
So it's hard for him
to pretend he suddenly
has a bad hand by checking.
And with the pot
already so big, he
can get a large percent of our
remaining stack into the pot
just by betting instead
of check-raising.
So it seems like it's less
likely he's checking as a trap.
And also, the ace is
sort of a better card
for his range than
ours because he's
the one who's been
betting, so having draws,
having overcards like aces--
and for us, we're much less
likely than him to have an ace.
So if it's a better
card for his range,
he should be betting both for
value and with his bluffs.
So that being said,
so let's suppose
we assume it's
sort of unlikely he
has a really, really good
hand, but he could so easily
have a hand that beats ours
and calls our potential bluff.
So OK, so now let's go back
to PokerStove and eliminate
some more hands.
OK, so what are some
hands we can eliminate
after he checks the river?
AUDIENCE: Aces.
WILL MA: Aces, yeah.
I think that's a good one.
I think aces, pretty clearly,
he'll bet again on the river.
What's another hand?
AUDIENCE: King-jack.
WILL MA: Yeah, king-jack
I think he might.
OK, so let's eliminate
all other good hands
that we think he's going
to continuation bet, right?
I think with any
straight, I think
it's reasonable to
assume they're just
going to keep betting.
Like nine-seven-- even
though it's nowhere near
the monster it was
on the flop, it still
only loses to jack-nine
and king-jack.
So let's get rid of that one.
AUDIENCE: Certainly
like ace-queen--
all those.
WILL MA: Yeah, I think most
strong two pairs I think,
definitely, he'll keep betting.
So let's get rid of that.
Let's get rid of ace-queen.
Let's get rid of queen-queen.
Let's get rid of queen-10.
I think queen-10 is good enough.
Ace-eight-- let's
get rid of that one--
yeah, that's good enough.
Pocket eights, pocket sixes
I think is good enough.
OK, good.
So OK, we've got
some hands here--
basically, all the
good hands we removed--
all the really good
hands that he bets again.
What do you guys
think about 10-8?
I guess it doesn't
matter too much.
Let's assume he checks
10-8 because by this river,
10-8 is no longer the
powerhouse it was.
Oh, I've got to get
rid of jack-nine.
OK, what are some other hands
you think we can eliminate?
So there there's actually
another category of hands
we could, potentially,
eliminate here.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: He would
probably bet an ace.
WILL MA: Well an ace
isn't that good of a hand.
So this is one problem
with this analysis
is, it is very
subject to debate what
we think about our opponent.
But for the sake of
this exercise, I'd say--
I mean also I
think in practice--
I think it's not clear that you
should value bet an ace here.
Because there's
just a lot of stuff
that beats you-- a lot of
straights, a lot of two pairs.
I think that even if
you have a ace-king,
you shouldn't really
be confident enough
in your hand to bet.
Like maybe ace-king is
marginal but definitely
not like ace-seven.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Bluff bets-- so like
weak hands, maybe six-four.
WILL MA: Great, great.
Yeah, exactly, so that's
what I wanted to hear.
So we can also eliminate some
of his really weak hands.
This is crucial.
This is an easy thing to miss.
We can probably
assume he's not going
to have king-seven because
the ace is a reasonable card
to bluff.
It's not great-- it's not
like the ace of clubs,
which would be a better
card for him to bluff,
but if he's got nothing--
like if he just
completely missed--
probably-- I mean,
let's assume you
know these guys are
pretty good players.
He's probably going to bluff.
So let's assume he
at least has a pair.
He has some showdown value,
because if he had zero showdown
value, he would have bluffed.
So let's get rid of king-seven,
let's get rid of king-nine.
Six-five six-four-- I
think, definitely, he
should be bluffing,
but maybe some players
will see a pair of
sixes and say, oh I
have enough showdown value.
So let's get rid of one
of them but not the other.
Maybe that's reasonable.
So let's get rid of two.
So let's get of
six-four and seven-six
but keep in six-five
and nine-six.
OK, so we leave
ourselves with these.
OK, so this seems about
reasonable, I think.
Let's eliminate ace-seven.
I think we should have
eliminated it on the turn.
Maybe like ace-seven of clubs we
can-- oh no, ace-seven of clubs
he can't have because we
have the seven of clubs.
I think any other ace-seven
other than the ace-seven
of clubs is kind of bad to bet
on the turn because the seven
isn't really that
good of a card to--
isn't that good of a draw.
So let's get rid of ace-seven.
So let's just suppose it's this.
OK, so that was a lot of work.
OK, so now roughly
speaking, we can
conclude his range on the
river is something like this.
So let's assume that
he's going to call
with top pair or better.
Once again, this is a
pretty strong assumption,
but let's suppose
this is the way
we think he's going to play.
He's going to call if
he has an ace or better
and fold other ones.
So we're risking 70 to win 100.
So let's do an exact
calculation now
of how many combinations
of these hands.
I'll do this on Notepad.
OK, let me pull up the board.
OK, hopefully,
people can see this.
So when I said
combinatorial hand analysis,
I mean we're going
to, basically,
count the combinations.
And like you pointed
out, this is--
oh crap, did I accidentally
get rid of that?
Oh, that's not good.
OK, let me quickly put it back.
So OK, we had kings left,
ace-king, ace-jack, ace-nine,
king-queen, queen-jack,
queen-nine, what else?
10-8, 10-6, eight-six--
we had some sixes, right?
Seven-six, six-five--
and is there something
else I'm missing?
Does anyone remember
if there's something
I'm forgetting to check off?
I knocked queen-nine
off, I guess.
I think this about right.
Maybe I'm missing like
one or two things.
No one sees anything?
I think this is approximately
what we had, right?
OK, hopefully I
didn't miss enough
that it drastically changes.
It shouldn't.
OK, so let's count
the combinations.
Because you can look at the
square on the PokerStove and--
let me clear this
annotation-- sorry,
I should've done
that a while ago.
OK, so you can see the
yellow hands on the square
and roughly see how
many hands of each type.
There's, essentially, three
types of hands he could have.
There's hands that call, there's
hands that beat us and call,
there's hands that
beat us and fold,
and there's hands
that we beat and fold.
But the thing is, if you just
look at these yellow squares,
it won't give you the right
probabilities because we
have certain cards in our hand.
And also, because
of the specific ways
suited combinations
work, there's
different combinations
of each hand.
So OK, let's go through this.
So how many combinations of
ace-king suited are there
that-- so we assume he
had a backdoor flush draw
on the flop, but--
so how many combinations of
ace-king suited are possible?
Don't worry about the
backdoor flush draw part.
It doesn't matter
for this example.
So how many combinations
of ace-king suited, Will?
Three.
Because it has to be suited.
And it can't be spades
because the ace of spades
is on the board.
So it's three combinations.
OK, ace-jack suited?
AUDIENCE: Three.
WILL MA: Three, OK, good.
Ace-nine suited?
AUDIENCE: Three.
WILL MA: Three.
OK, good.
All right, pocket kings?
AUDIENCE: About six?
WILL MA: Right, so
pocket kings is six.
Because there's no kings;
we don't see any kings,
and there's no such
thing as suitedness.
So yeah, so one thing
you realize in this--
oh, so pocket kings we're
assuming he's going to fold--
one thing you will
realize in this exercise
is, you've got to
put a lot of weight
on the offsuit hands
instead of the suited hands.
Because the offsuit hands,
combinatorially, have way more
possibilities-- essentially
three times as many
possibilities-- as
the suited hands.
So like this queen-jack
offsuit in here
has a huge weight
in our calculation.
That's by far his
most likely hand.
Because it's the only offsuit
hand we're putting him on.
Yeah, it's the only offsuit--
is it really only the offsuit
hand that he could have?
I guess according
to our analysis,
we're assuming the
only offsuit hand he
could have is queen-jack off.
So how many combinations of
queen-jack off are there?
AUDIENCE: 12.
WILL MA: OK, so let's just
say queen-jack in total.
Queen-jack suited
plus offsuit is 12.
Because we see a queen,
so there's four jacks,
three queens, three
times four is 12.
It could be suited
or not suited.
So OK, that counts
for both of those.
What about king-queen suited?
AUDIENCE: Three as well?
WILL MA: So it's three as well,
but I'm going to put it as two
because I can assume if he
had king-queen of spades,
which has no flush dras-- like
no runner-runner flush draw
on the flop--
I'm going to assume that he
would have folded king-queen
of spades on the flop.
So I'm going to give it two.
OK, so which ones
haven't we done?
Queen-nine suited,
how many combinations?
Three?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
WILL MA: OK, 10-8
suited, these get five.
So the reason why
10-8 is suited is
because we're assuming he
doesn't raise 10-8 offsuit
preflop from that position.
So that's why 10-8
has to be suited.
So how many combinations
of 10-8 suited?
Two.
OK, how many combinations
of 10-6 suited?
AUDIENCE: Two as well.
WILL MA: Two.
How many combinations
of eight-six suited?
AUDIENCE: One?
WILL MA: One, yes.
OK.
I miscategorized this one.
So queen-nine is in this
category that he's folding.
These are all the hands that
call our bluff and beat us.
And so the last
category is the hands
that we can actually
beat if we check it down.
So it's very small.
It's just seven-six
and six-five suited.
OK, so seven-six suited,
how many combinations?
AUDIENCE: Two?
WILL MA: Two.
Six-five suited, three?
OK.
Did I miss anything?
I think this is it, right?
OK, so basically we
have to tally it up.
So here, there's 14.
Here, there's 23.
And here, there's five.
OK so now that we've
done this calculation,
we need to, basically,
run the numbers
with these calculations.
So essentially,
roughly speaking,
they're going to fold
more than half the time.
So the numbers-- I
think this will actually
come out close
because with the way
we did this specific
calculation,
I think we gave him a lot
of combinations of hands
that we can actually
check and beat.
But I think this is still--
this will still definitely
call for a bluff.
But it close.
If you've done the homework,
the homework sort of
addresses this, right?
It's not just the probability
he's calling our bluff,
it's the probability
he's calling
our bluff versus the probability
we win the hand by checking.
And the probability we win the
hand by checking is roughly 5
out of 42--
so which is pretty small, and he
folds more than half the time.
So if you run the
numbers, you'll
see that bluffing is
overwhelmingly profitable.
And I think this
is a good example
of why this combinatorial
analysis is good--
is because if you
look at PokerStove
and you look at this,
you might actually think
bluffing is bad because you
look at most of the hands--
ace-king, ace-jack,
ace-nine, 10-8, 10-6, 8-6--
it's hands that
call us and beat us,
but when you do this
combinatorial analysis,
you'll realize there's way
more combinations of queen-jack
than there are eight-six.
So looking at this
itself isn't quite enough
because this doesn't weight
the probabilities of each one
correctly.
So this is a good
exercise to do, I think.
Even though we made a lot
of assumptions in our model,
but it's a very good
exercise to do after the fact
to sort of just analyze
what are the different-- all
the different possibilities.
OK, so I'm going to
take a quick break here.
And then for the last
half of the class,
I'm going to just talk about
some general poker topics.
So no math.
No poker hands.
But just some general stuff
about poker and some ending
remarks since this
is the last time
I'm teaching since Bill
Chen is coming next time.
If you want to, during the
break, think about any question
you might want to ask me
about poker in general--
or specific-- and--
yeah-- so we'll take
like a 10-minute break.
Make sure you hand
in the homework.
All right, so I'm
going to wrap up
with some general thoughts about
poker and poker in general.
So one question that
I get asked a lot
is, it's called the
Moneymaker effect.
So what happened-- and this
is sort of a big catalyst
for poker becoming
really popular--
was, I think in 2003,
Chris Moneymaker,
that's actually his name--
Moneymaker is his last name--
he spent like $1 playing in
this satellite on PokerStars,
won a seat to the World
Series of Poker main event,
and then went there, and
then won the whole thing
for like $2.5 million.
It was a beautiful
Cinderella story,
and then people heard this.
And also, they made it
seem like, you know,
it's not like the lottery
where you've got to get really,
really lucky to become rich.
It's literally, this
guy's really smart.
He can read people,
and it's all skill.
And he did this.
And it's sort of like, anyone
can become a poker star just
like Chris Moneymaker.
And this was a
huge driving force
in the popularity of poker.
So a question that I
wondered myself is,
how could there actually
be so much money?
Because someone has to be
losing this money for you
to be winning this money, right?
So where is the
money coming from?
Can anyone smart and
motivated succeed in poker?
Et cetera.
OK, so what's
unique about poker?
Why can't you make
this much money playing
like chess or something?
Why can't you make this
much money playing hockey?
So what's unique about poker?
So I guess four unique
aspects that allows
for there to be so much money.
So I'm going to talk
about them individually.
One is, I think everyone is
overconfident, myself included.
Two is, gambling
self-control-- aspects of that.
Three is, it's a very
fast-evolving game.
And four is, what I sort
of started the class--
the very first class I talked
about being credit card
roulette-- not being
results-oriented.
And I think that's very hard.
So I'll go through each
one of them separately.
So yeah, one is this huge
overconfidence thing,
which is very prevalent.
So it's normal, in general,
for people to be overconfident.
I don't know how many of you
have seen the experiment where
it's like, you know, write
down your 95% confidence
intervals for all these things.
So if they're actually
95% confidence intervals
and they're
correctly calibrated,
then actually 19 out
of 20 of your intervals
should contain the real thing.
But like you do this
for a normal person,
it'll be like, 30% of their
things actually lie neutral.
So they're just
drastically overconfident.
And so yeah, it's normal to be
overconfident, but especially
in poker.
I think poker is
among the things
I know where it's
easiest to overestimate
your own abilities.
Does someone want to
suggest any others?
Is there something else
you think where like,
everyone thinks they're
good at this thing?
So I can think of two examples
that I think are sort of true.
Raise your hand if you think
you're a below medium driver.
No, but some people actually
are willing to do it.
Because I very rarely talk
to someone who admitted
to being bad at driving.
Everyone I've ever asked
about their driving skill
thinks they're really good at
driving a car, myself included.
I definitely don't think
I'm a below medium driver.
Another thing is teaching.
I've also barely
talked to someone
who thinks they're worse
than medium at teaching.
I guess maybe
Professor [INAUDIBLE]
can speak about this.
Most things someone will
admit to being bad at this,
but poker is similar to these
two examples I thought of--
driving, teaching, sort of.
Where it's just very easy to
think you're really good at it,
and it's hard to admit to
yourself that you're not
good at it.
Yeah, so one saying in poker
is, if you can't spot the fish
at the table-- the fish is like
the losing player that everyone
is trying to win money from--
then you are the fish.
This is sort of
a popular saying.
So why is overconfidence
so common in poker?
It's like a mental battle.
Your mentally battling
against your opponent.
Is he bluffing?
Is he not?
And it's just easy
to always assume--
which I do throughout a
lot of this class, right?
I talk about exploitative play.
I'm building a model
for our opponent
and assuming that they behave
as a probabilistic machine
according to my model.
I'm assuming that I'm
ahead of my opponent.
I'm assuming I'm better.
There's also a lot of
selective memory, I think.
It's easy to remember
your bad beats--
the time they hit a king on
the river and beat your aces--
and it's easy to forget the
times you got really lucky
on the river and beat them.
So selective memory, I
think, is a big aspect.
I think lack of clear benchmarks
is a big aspect as well.
So it's not like
running 100 meters.
No one who takes 30
seconds to run 100 meters
is going to think, oh, I can
compete in the Olympics, right?
Because it's very clear.
There's a very clear benchmark
how fast you need to be.
But in poker, even if you
don't win tournaments,
it's easy to
complain about luck.
And there's different
types of tournaments.
And it's easy to like bend
the benchmarks in a way
to convince yourself that
you're better than you are.
It's easy to hit a lucky streak
and consider it all skill,
and you can blame all your
losing streaks on luck.
So those are some
reasons I think.
I think poker is just a
very well-designed game
for this purpose
and to, basically,
tricking and deceiving
people into overestimating
their own ability.
And another aspect
of it is, and this
is what's really tough
poker, I think, is,
even though it's so easy
to be overconfident,
and it's such a flaw to be
overconfident, it's also,
in some sense, necessary.
You know, if you're
not confident,
how can you take risks?
Poker-- you're
gambling, essentially,
and you have to do risky things.
And if you're not confident, how
can you do risky things, right?
And also, if you're trying to
mentally read your opponent,
if you're constantly
remind yourself
that you're dumber than you
think you are, then how can
you actually think that you
can outread your opponent?
And I talked about
this results-oriented.
You need to be
confident to trust
that you made a good decision
even though your result was
you lost $10,000 on the day.
So confidence is also
necessary, but it's also so easy
to be overconfident.
So this balance of being
exactly the right confidence
is something that I think
even like professional poker
players strive to try to strike
the balance between every day.
And I think it's very tough.
And it's something I
struggle with a lot,
too, to try to figure out
when I'm being overconfident
and when I'm being
underconfident.
So I think one good mentality--
so back to this driving thing
is, I think it's a good
mentality-- you know,
if you play poker
and you enjoy it.
I think it's a great game.
It's a beautiful mathematical
game and a fun game
to play with friends
if you're just
are willing to admit, you
know, I play in this home game
every Friday night.
I'm probably a below
average player.
I probably lose, on average,
$10 every time I play.
I think that's totally fine.
It's just like
spending your Friday
night going to see a movie.
You pay $10 and you're happy
to take $10 out of your wallet
and not see it again, right?
I think it would be a healthy
mentality for more people
to be willing to do this and
just admit to themselves,
yeah, I enjoy playing poker,
and I lose a bit of money,
but you know, I
have fun doing it.
And it's the same
as seeing a movie
but, in reality, I think
this isn't the case.
Even at these friendly Friday
night games for low stakes,
probably, if you ask
all the people there,
do you think you're
beating your friends?
Everyone's going to say yes.
Everyone's not saying, oh,
I'm going there, essentially,
paying $10 to play
poker with my friends.
Everyone's saying, I'm winning
a bit of money or whatever,
right?
So I think that's an important
mentality to try to have that.
And I think it's fine.
You don't have to be the
best at everything, right?
So one story I like to
tell is, so David Einhorn--
he's like a billionaire.
I think he founded Greenlight
Capital or something.
And he actually won $4
million in a $1 million
buy-in poker tournament and
donated it all to charity.
And after the fact--
he's always like a
super smart guy--
so he played a $1 million
buy-in tournament.
So everyone else playing this
tournament is like a poker
professional-- the
best in the world--
and he's just like this
rich billionaire who
doesn't really--
like he wasn't bad,
but he just started
playing poker.
Like, he's a smart guy, and
he got coaching to play it,
but he was the clear
loser in the tournament.
And he just admitted it.
He just said you know,
I'm a billionaire.
I'm happy to spend
a million dollars
playing this tournament.
I understand I'm probably
expecting to lose like $200,000
or whatever playing this
tournament with all these guys,
but I'm fine with it.
I got a million dollars,
who cares, right?
And he was just very honest.
And even after he
actually won $4 million,
he didn't come first,
he came like third--
he just admitted, you know, he
said like, I was very lucky.
I came in expecting to
just lose this $1 million
that I don't care
about, and then
he just donated all his
winnings to charity, anyway.
But I wish more
people were like him.
I think that's a
very good mentality
to have to just admit that
you're playing poker for fun,
and that's totally fine.
OK, so the second thing
I want to talk about
is gambling self-control.
So I think this can
also be the downfall
of a lot of smart and
motivated people trying
to get into poker.
So these are some
things that can happen.
So after getting unlucky
in the previous hand,
you play the next hand
poorly because you're upset.
You're tilted, as
poker player say.
Or playing when you're
tired just to get unstuck.
I've definitely done this
many times before in my poker
career.
If I lost money,
especially when I
feel like I'd gotten unlucky
playing against someone
who I'm better
than and just like,
I've lost money
because I got unlucky,
I won't stop playing until I
get unstuck, which is like,
win back the money I lost until
I'm in the black, essentially.
And it's terrible because
even if I'm a bit better,
if I'm playing with
this mentality trying
to get unstuck, I'm
just going to be making
below average decisions, and
it's just not a good thing
to do.
And also from the
other side, it can be
hard to rationalize gambling.
So it's hard to stop yourself
from gambling too much,
but it's also sometimes hard
to rationalize that, you know,
gambling-- there is a lot
of stigma around gambling.
You have to convince
yourself that, I
shouldn't be too scared.
I'm playing this game
that involves-- you know,
you can call it gambling--
I'm playing this game
with a lot of luck.
And you've got to convince
yourself that, this
is what I'm fine with doing.
It's like a lottery.
And you've got to
sometimes make decisions
under pressure as well.
And you've just got to
rationalize to yourself
that, yeah, there's a
lot of luck in this,
but this is the game
I chose to play.
The third thing is--
so fast evolution, I think,
is another big aspect
of how there was so much money
in Texas hold 'em for so long.
So it was a relatively
new game, also
with a lot of hidden depth.
So something like
this can never happen
in chess, where chess
has been studied
for hundreds,
thousands of years,
and it's not like a new game.
And even though the best player
today is still better than
the best player 20 years ago,
it's not like the game is
evolving super fast, whereas
hold 'em was like a new game--
a relatively new
game at the time.
And just-- there was
so much hidden depth,
and the best players just
kept improving so fast that--
so like you say, like the
best player in the year
2000 would be like a
terrible player by 2004.
And like the best player in
2004 would be a bad player
by 2008, et cetera.
So it's just, even if
you're on top of the game
right now, if you
stop studying, you're
going to be nowhere near the
top of the game in like a year.
So it was just so fast.
Can anyone else think of
other examples of things
that are kind of like this?
AUDIENCE: CrossFit was--
well, if you get like--
the winner of the 2009-2010
games wouldn't even compete.
WILL MA: Oh, wow.
OK I didn't know that.
That's cool.
I didn't know CrossFit
was that good, yeah.
That's pretty crazy.
There's one other thing
I can sort of think of.
How many you guys have done
math contests as a kid?
I think those, to my knowledge,
have gotten a lot harder,
just in terms of
how good you need
to be to say, be on the
United States national team
is way harder now than it was,
say, 30 years ago from what
I've heard.
But yeah, so this
aspect of Texas hold
'em-- so this was also
a huge driving factor.
Because it would be
easy to tell yourself,
I was the best player in
the world four years ago.
I could obviously sit down at
this $1/$2 game and make money,
right?
And the answer
would often be, no.
So this was another reason why
there was a lot of money in it.
Because it's easy
to just remember
that you were the best
a year ago and just
forget that the tides
are rising so fast.
So that being said, so I wanted
to also take this opportunity
to suggest some
further readings for--
I know I've been asked this.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So why is that?
Based on your understanding?
I think because of
your strategies--
you have to improve
your strategy?
WILL MA: Yeah,
yeah, I also think
there was a lot of hidden depth.
So I mean, I think with any new
thing, this will be the case.
But I think in poker,
there were many times
where the consensus amongst
the top players was that they
were close to solving the game.
And then a year
later, they would
realize they missed completely
viable strategies that
completely messed up
all their calculations,
and they had to start over.
So I think that was big.
It's easy to think that
you've solved the game
and then suddenly
realize, oh, I'm
nowhere near solving the game
because I forgot about all
of these different strategies.
This might be sort of
true with a lot of--
I'm trying to think, I mean--
the biggest thing
is, it's a new thing.
Like it's hard for
this to happen like--
I think in most
sports that people
have done for a long time,
people get gradually better,
right?
You look at like,
the 100-meter sprint.
It's like, yeah, the world
record is getting broken,
but it's not like it's
going to go from 10 seconds
to five seconds.
It'll go from 10 seconds to 9.99
seconds or something like that.
So I think just the fact that
it's new is a big aspect.
But yeah, Texas hold 'em would
be the equivalent to the world
record in the 100 meters
being 10 seconds then
like five seconds
a year later, then
like two seconds like two years
later, it was just insane.
OK, so that being said, so
some people have asked me,
if I want to continue learning
about poker and reading poker,
what should I do?
So that being said, I think
the best resources, by far,
are online.
A lot of people have
asked me about books,
and I will recommend some books,
but I think books, basically,
blew out of date way too fast.
So I think, in general, the
best resources are online.
So cardrunners.com is a website
where, basically, poker pros
can make videos of themselves
while playing and talking.
You do have to pay to
get a subscription.
OK, so this is a bit of a
biased advice, just a warning,
because I'm a pro
at CardRunners,
but, I mean, amongst
like 50, 60 other pros.
They also donated
some free memberships
to students in the class if
you guys looked at the prizes.
So you can get some free
memberships to CardRunners.
A good free resource
is Two Plus Two forums.
I think there's a lot of
garbage on those forums nowadays
but, still, most of the best
poker players in the world
still do use those forums and
posts on those forums-- so
twoplustwo.com.
There is a lot of
garbage and banter,
but if you are just
trying to improve,
there is good content on there.
You just have to find it.
So this is a new thing,
but on Twitch streams--
so Twitch is a website
you can go on to watch,
essentially, poker
pros play in real time.
They share their screens and
talk through their hands.
It's a pretty good
free resource.
It's sometimes more
entertaining than educational,
but I think it's quite good.
And they would do
like a 10-minute delay
so that you can't watch them and
you know what cards they have.
In case anyone was
considering trying
to do that to get an advantage.
So these are some
online resources,
and I will suggest
some books, although I
do think most of these books, I
think, are reasonably outdated.
But I do think they're
very-- in my opinion,
out of the books
I've read, these
are the best-written books.
And even if they're
a bit outdated,
I think the theory and
the way they're written
is very good and also
somewhat entertaining
and sort of gives you an
idea on the history of poker
and the evolution of the game.
So my favorite book
is the first one.
It's called, Small
Stakes Hold 'em.
It's by Ed Miller, who's a
MIT graduate; David Sklansky;
and Mason Malmuth.
So this is actually
limit hold 'em,
which is, in some sense,
a solved game nowadays,
and no one plays limit
hold 'em anymore.
So limit hold 'em is where
you can't bet any amount.
You have to bet a
very specific size.
But I think this is one
of the classic books.
So this is one of the
classic books in poker.
It's very well written and
written by mathematicians.
And it just goes through
the basic concepts of poker,
I think, very, very well, even
though it's for limit hold 'em.
And it's a good read.
Yeah, it might even be a
collector's item nowadays.
So one story I'd like to
tell about this book is--
so my good friend,
Mike McDonald, he was--
so he's the guy who
got me into poker.
He's probably read this
book, he says like--
maybe like 20 times.
And then he's also a guy who
doesn't really like reading.
So I think there was
a point in his life
where he's read less than 20
different books in his life
but then this specific
book more than 20 times.
So it's a very good book.
Harrington on Hold
'em is on tournaments.
It's outdated.
It's really, really
badly outdated,
but I still think it's
very well written and has
some good concepts.
That's how I first
started learning
to play tournaments is
Harrington on Hold 'em 1 and 2.
Kill Phil/ Kill Everyone
I think is pretty good,
pretty up to date--
it's decent, I think.
Every Hand Revealed is--
Gus Hansen's a very
famous poker player
who's been around forever.
So it's a book where he goes
through every hand he played
in this tournament that he won.
And I think it's more
entertaining than educational,
but he's definitely
a really good player.
Mathematics of
Poker by Bill Chen.
It's not that practical-- don't
tell Bill this when he comes
Friday--
it's theoretically very
interesting if you like math--
if you like game theory.
It's theoretically
very interesting.
Building a Bankroll is
a recent book that--
this year, he didn't
have any leftovers
to donate to our class
but, in the past,
he's supported our
class and donated
a lot of copies of the book.
And I think it's pretty up to
date, and it's for cash games,
so I think it's very good.
OK, so back to the four things
about poker that I think
makes it unique.
So the fourth point is this idea
of not being results-oriented.
So yeah, so we talked
about this a lot
in the first class already--
this decision mentality, where
you need to care about
the decision you made,
not the result you got.
And I think this
actually is a barrier
to a lot of smart and
motivated people getting
into poker because it's
almost antithetical.
If you're a smart and motivated
person, you're used to like--
you study hard, and then you
get a good result on your tests,
right?
If you get a failing
grade in your test,
you're never going to be
able to go up to your parents
and be like, oh, I
make good decisions,
but I just got really unlucky
and failed the test, right?
No one's going to believe you.
In poker, this can
happen all the time.
So it is a bit antithetical
to sort of being motivated.
One thing poker players
like to laugh at
is, I don't know if you put
the word, results-oriented
on your resume?
I've seen seminars that
teach you to become
"results-oriented," and
advertising this as being
a great thing.
You achieve results.
You work hard, make decisions,
and you achieve results.
But we always laugh at this.
Because results-oriented
is always
a negative term in poker.
If a poker player says
someone is results-oriented,
they don't respect
them very much.
But I've seen resume's
where people say,
I'm very results-oriented.
So a related thing is,
it's easy to underestimate
the variance in poker.
And this is a big
aspect, too, that goes on
with being results-oriented.
So this statistical
experiment involving making up
sequences of coin flips--
I've heard of this
where a professor would
ask students to make up a
sequence of 200 coin flips.
Can we get half the
class to do this?
And then can we get the other
half to actually flip 200 coins
and write down like heads,
tails, heads, heads, heads,
tails?
And he could tell with
like 100% certainty
which ones are made up
and which ones were real.
And the way he did
this is basically
looking at which of the--
what's the longest
sequence of heads in a row
or tails in a row?
And basically, in reality,
if you flipped 200 coins--
I forget the exact
numbers, but I
think it's something
like, you're like 99%
to get at least like six
or seven of the same thing
in a row, whereas in
all the made-up ones
that people would be like,
oh if there was heads
seven times in a row, that
can't be random, right?
So we can't put
seven hands in a row.
So I think it's known that
it's easy to underestimate
how long you can get
unlucky looking for.
Like it's easy to think, I've
been unlucky the last three
times; that means I must
deserve to get lucky now.
But this is not
true, mathematically.
And it's just very
easy to underestimate
variance and underestimate
how likely it
is that you're just actually
going to lose 10 coin
flips in a row in poker.
It's going to happen to you,
and you're going to get tilted.
And it's very important
to control tilt.
And yeah, pretty much
every poker player
thinks they're unluckier
than mathematically possible.
I've definitely felt like this
in many parts of my career.
I still feel like
this sometimes now.
It's very easy to get this
feeling where you just,
how can it be possible?
How could I actually lose
20 coin flips in a row?
Well, it can happen.
And one of my poker players that
I was talking to, John Cannon,
he plays a lot of online
poker, and this is actually
a picture of his desk.
He, basically, was so angry
I think he smashed his mouse
and made a big hole in his desk.
So it can really frustrate you.
And I hate to say
this, but I think
even if you're
working very hard, you
do need some lucky big
scores along the way,
especially at the
start to get into it,
even if you're very smart
and working in the right way.
And this is also
antithetical and smart.
Antithetical to smart and
motivated people, right?
Because we want to believe
that if you work hard
and you're smart, then
you'll make it for sure.
But I wouldn't say
this is true in poker.
I mean, I think I'm willing
to admit that I think
I was very lucky at the start.
I had some big scores
at the start that
really drove my
interest in the game
and really propelled me
into professional poker.
And I think there probably,
in a parallel universe,
could be another copy of me
that did the exact same things
and just didn't get as
lucky as I did at the start
and just never got into poker.
So this fact that you do
still need to get lucky,
even if you make all the right
decisions [INAUDIBLE] make it
is--
It's sort of a tough
thing to swallow.
This is sort of a
different story,
but I'd like to argue that
that's sort of true in life,
too--
the fact that being
smart and working hard
doesn't guarantee
success by any means.
So although that's a
negative thing for poker,
I'd like to end with what
I call, "the joy of making
good decisions."
So even though not
everyone makes it in poker,
but poker players--
we like to talk about sort
of, you're not really there.
You shouldn't be trying to think
about making money or whatever.
You're sort of just
there to enjoy the game,
and have an honest
opinion on your ability,
and calibrate your confidence.
I've told the Bill Gates/Doyle
Brunson story but yeah,
basically, Bill Gates, I
think, was a pretty good poker
player for quite a while.
And he would make money.
And clearly, it was not
his best way to make money.
He could probably just go to
his company and make like $500
a second or something like that.
But when asked about it,
Bill Gates would just say,
I love making good decisions.
I love thinking about this
game and making decisions.
And even though, clearly, the
money means nothing to me,
it's still important to
me, as a personal goal,
to succeed at this
game and make money,
even though it
doesn't mean anything.
So it's about this joy
of making good decisions.
And I think part of the
reason Bill Gates was
able to be quite good was
because the money meant nothing
to him.
He didn't really care
about his results
and how much he made
or lost, clearly.
He just focused on making
the best decisions.
And so it is true that there's
a decent amount of luck in poker
but, yes, I would argue, life is
luck, and you only live once--
there's all these
sayings but, overall,
the thing to keep in mind is,
like Jennifer Shahade talked
about this with the
"Goldilocks" video--
so you want to think of your
life and/or your poker career
or whatever as one long session
where you're just trying
to make the best decisions.
And even if you don't get
the best results today,
hope that you get better
results throughout the course
of your life.
So yeah, that's the
end of what I wanted
to say about the
general poker and what
I hope you take
away from this class
from a non-mathematical,
non-poker point of view.
I guess there is a bit
of time for questions.
There's a lot of things
I didn't talk about,
but I'm happy to
answer questions about.
Yeah, I'm happy to answer
any questions, now.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Now that there are no
longer any class tournaments,
where can I go to play to
get better and improve?
WILL MA: So there's
an MIT poker club,
and they run tournaments
on PokerStars
similar to the way
the class works.
The way you can get
into the poker club
is so [INAUDIBLE] is part of it.
She's like one of the execs.
Maybe you should ask her.
Send her an email.
I can ask her.
I'll ask her, and I'll
send something to the class
if you guys are interested
in continuing playing
poker on PokerStars and--
yeah, so there's
the MIT Poker Club.
And I know in the
past, sometimes
the classes continued
playing tournaments
after the class is over.
We would have like a tournament
every Saturday or something
for people to play,
but I don't know if--
they didn't last very long.
I think people quickly
lost interest in it.
But yeah, I think
just the poker club.
Actually, Martin, you're
in the Poker Club, right?
So maybe you can something
to answer that question.
AUDIENCE: So sometimes we have
[INAUDIBLE] games where people
can play like $0.25,
$0.50 [INAUDIBLE]..
So there's like a
million you can get on.
WILL MA: OK, I'll
find some information
from [INAUDIBLE] and Martin.
I'll send something
to the class,
and I'll give you
guys some pointers.
AUDIENCE: How do
you, personally,
deal with downswing?
WILL MA: Yeah, so
definitely, I've
gone through bad
downswings and times
where I really hated the game.
I think I mostly
just took a break.
So yeah, I mostly
My first couple of downswings
when I was first starting,
I just took a break from
the game for a while,
like a month or something,
and then came back.
That's sort of what I did.
Nowadays, I'd say like the
last four years, I've been--
I'd like to think I was
fairly good at dealing
with downswings.
I sort of went through
enough downswings
where I kind of was able to
just keep it together through it
for the most part.
Like maybe I'd
play slightly less,
but I wouldn't quit altogether.
AUDIENCE: So for small cash
games online, what kind of edge
do you think you have?
WILL MA: For small?
AUDIENCE: And then
what kind of edge--
what is your like, borderline
edge where it suddenly wouldn't
become worth it anymore?
WILL MA: Oh, so how much
edge do I think I have?
So in online cash games--
the thing is, I don't really
specialize in cash games,
so I never really play them.
So I'd say it's
probably very little.
I mean, I'm sure I can find
low enough stakes where
I'll have a significant edge--
AUDIENCE: Or even in
tournaments, then?
Online small stakes tournaments?
WILL MA: Yeah, yeah,
so in tournaments, I'd
say there's still a decent
edge, and I'll play it for--
but mostly, I'd I'll play
poker, mostly, for fun nowadays.
I rarely force myself to do
it for making money, I'd say.
Most of the time
I'm playing, I'm
still trying to
make good decisions
because I enjoy doing
that, but I'm not really
doing it for the power
degree or whatever.
AUDIENCE: So what about maybe
the best cash-game player
in the world, how much would
they make in about $0.25/$0.50
online?
WILL MA: Oh, $0.25/$0.50 online?
So I don't have a great sense
of this, but let me think.
So the thing is, the players who
are sort of considered the top
players in the world who
play like very high stakes--
like nosebleeds stakes with
like $100/$200 big blinds
or something--
it's sort of, the
variance is so high
that it's not really
accepted who's
the best because if it
was accepted, you know,
someone had a win rate
over someone else,
then the guy who was worse
just wouldn't be playing.
So the only reason
those games run
is because they all think
they have a win rate.
So it's hard for me
to say the number
because I'm not
going to know better
than what they're true win
rates are against each other.
And they're all going to
tell me something different,
because they all think they're
beating the other guys.
As far as how much
a really top player
can win at a low-stakes
game, it's still
going to be very significant.
I think making something maybe
like, five or six big blinds
per 100.
Yeah, five or six big
blinds per 100, I think,
is maybe doable at a
reasonably low stakes--
if you're like one
of the very best.
It's quite a lot.
It's quite generous.
But let's say every 100 hands
you make five big blinds.
So let's say you
play $0.25/$0.50,
five big blinds is $250.
You make that every 100 hands.
If you play six tables, you
can get in about 100 hands
per hour, 120 hands per hour.
So that's 600 hands per hour.
So it's six times
$250; so it's like $15.
So it's not a lot, but I mean
those guys can play stakes way
higher than $0.25/$0.50 and
still have a slightly smaller
edge.
So if you imagine
they play 250/$5.
Then suddenly, you multiply,
then that'll give me about $10.
I mean you would be decreasing
it because they probably
wouldn't make five
big blinds per hour--
five big blinds per 100.
But I think those numbers
are ballpark correct, yeah.
All right, yeah?
AUDIENCE: What's a good
for playing at a casino,
like exploiting people?
WILL MA: What's a good strategy
for playing at a casino
and exploiting people?
One general thing that's
going to do is, you go there--
you sleep at night, and you go
there at like 7:00 AM and play
against people who have
been tilted and angry for--
[LAUGHTER]
And you just woke up
at 7 AM in the morning.
And you're in such a good mood,
and they're all in a bad mood,
and you can win a lot of money.
In terms of specific
strategy, I think
it depends a lot on the player.
I think, in general, playing
tight is pretty good.
At least I'd say
I consider myself,
in general, a
tight player, and I
think a decent
amount of money can
be made at casinos against
recreational players
just by them getting bored.
Like at a nine-headed table,
you're only paying the blinds--
1 and 1/2 blinds
every nine hands.
You can easily
get away with only
playing like pocket nines
plus, ace-queen plus.
I mean, that's extreme, but
they'll probably still call you
because they're bored.
They're not going to
think like, this guy's--
I'm going to just fold--
so one disadvantage
of that strategy
is, they're just always
going to fold to you.
But in practice, I don't
think that's what happens.
So I think, in
general, playing tight
will always be a pretty
good strategy at casinos
against recreational players.
AUDIENCE: Yeah?
Do you have any
advice for avoiding
this pitfall of thinking you're
good and you're not actually?
WILL MA: Not really, because
I think it's happened to me
a lot of times.
Yeah, I think it really is
hard to judge, especially
in tournaments.
In cash games, it's
slightly easier
to judge because you can just
look at your data points,
and it'll converge faster.
In tournaments, the variance
is so high you can't really
use your tournament results.
I think the most important
thing, for me personally,
was just talking to players and
having very honest friends who
would tell me if they thought
I was worse than someone else
and tell them not to play them.
And I think that's
probably the thing that
benefited me the most-- just
being able to talk to players
better than me or at
a similar level to me
and just getting their opinion
from them talking to me.
If they think I'm not good
enough, I want them to tell me.
And I think that's one of the
most important things is just
getting good feedback from your
friends and honest feedback.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Since we
can't play online here,
and we can't do it at the
casino like every weekend--
so we can't play for money--
what's some good motivation
to keep the Saturday game?
Is this like poker
mentality, and these kids
will have development
in whatever they
like [INAUDIBLE] jobs?
WILL MA: OK, so I'll
address a few things.
So one thing that I didn't
really formally announce--
but yeah, so one
thing you pointed out
is, playing online
poker for money
is illegal in Massachusetts.
The police can't
come arrest you,
but the website will
take all your money
if they find out you're
playing from Massachusetts.
But I don't believe it's
written in Massachusetts
law or something.
To my knowledge, the
police can't arrest you.
But yeah, so the question
was, if we can't play online,
what can we do?
So I think it is legal
in New Jersey and Nevada.
So you can move to
New Jersey or Nevada.
OK, yeah, so if you don't
want to go to the casino
every weekend, so
what else can you do?
OK, so what's the
motivation to keep playing?
So I think I've
tried in this class
to give examples
of where I think
poker is very useful, just in
terms of how poker is related
to nonpoker stuff, like
calibrating your confidence,
figuring out what your biases
are, and stuff like that.
And I also think
it's a fun game.
It's a very fun game.
It's mathematically interesting.
But yeah, I mean, if you don't
enjoy playing the game much,
and sense you can't really
make money playing it
in Massachusetts, yeah, then,
if both of those are true,
then there's not
that much reason
to play it if you
don't enjoy it.
I think that's just
the biggest thing.
If you enjoy it and you
enjoy the decision-making,
I think it's very fun, and
it's also very good for you.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
WILL MA: All right, cool.
Yeah, so if there's
no more questions,
then I guess we'll call
it here, and then Friday
will be the last class.
There's two more nights
of tournaments left.
And yeah, I'm excited for
Friday for Bill's lecture
and to hand out the prizes.